Sathya Narayanan: Thanks, Jeff. So quickly, I just… I created a Canvas assignment where you can submit the Google Doc if you,
Sathya Narayanan: if you don't mind, just submitting it there, I think that would be… that would be great.
Sathya Narayanan: I hope I didn't put it in the wrong order and everybody has access to it.
Sathya Narayanan: Let me quickly make sure that everybody has access to it.
Sathya Narayanan: Maybe I'll put it here.
Sathya Narayanan: Okay, so hopefully everybody has access to it. I wanted to quickly, give you a,
Sathya Narayanan: kind of summary of the plan going forward. So there is this assignment, called
Sathya Narayanan: set up your dojo, so you used our symbiotic thinking dojo tool, but I walk you through how to set it up on your own chatbot. So I have a video here, and then I have instructions on how you can set it up on your own chatbot.
Sathya Narayanan: The motivation behind this is to help you
Sathya Narayanan: I know some of you maybe already know how to use projects on AI, but this hopefully will give you some guidance if you don't know how to
Sathya Narayanan: be partnered with AI to kind of use it in your career search, like, they should give you guidance on this. So please watch this video, follow these instructions to set up the dojo, and then…
Sathya Narayanan: I still use, kind of, class language, I apologize, like, no, that's how I'm used to… I've been doing this for 20 years. I call this assignments and all that, but it's basically activities we are recommending that's going to help you with your… with your job search. So there is a…
Sathya Narayanan: Once you set up the dojo, here is guidance on how you could use the dojo to,
Sathya Narayanan: dig deeper, so even, you know, some of the things that I'm looking at, like, there are additional things I want to kind of provide feedback, but we can't do that for everybody. Our hope is this kind of a structure is going to provide you with more precise feedback. The dojo structure is built based on a lot of
Sathya Narayanan: ideas Jeff had about, like, what makes a good resume. I will highlight this, I'll ask you to look at this, so this is a… so Larslo Bach has written some books on this, like, he's considered one of the
Sathya Narayanan: he used to be, SVP of PeopleOps in Google. He's written books about this.
Sathya Narayanan: So this is basically something he published, and I used it in building the dojo tool. But you can actually just read the source. If you don't want to use my Dojo, that's perfectly fine. I hope you do, I hope it helps you. He really has the… this is something I want to emphasize, like, I've heard this so many times from him and others.
Sathya Narayanan: I see this in a lot of students' resumes still.
Sathya Narayanan: there is process statements, right? I worked on something, but not accomplishment statements.
Sathya Narayanan: Resume needs to have… process is okay, but it at least should be 50% accomplishment statement, if not more. And he emphasizes this a lot, and he kind of has this formula that
Sathya Narayanan: he's talked about many times. I think, like, Jeff hinted at it when he said, like, you know, you have an interest, but where is the evidence for it? Kind of a thing, right? And using this structure is very helpful, so I would encourage you to look at this resource.
Sathya Narayanan: And… Try to do…
Sathya Narayanan: like, deep dive on your resume. Again, like, think about that idea of, like, in one-third of… the first one-third of your resume, people should want to talk to you.
Sathya Narayanan: Right? And that's a relatively high bar, right? Like, it's not a simple thing to do. It's not impossible, or it's not, like, magic or anything, but it is not…
Sathya Narayanan: There is an amount of effort needed to do that, like, you just need to dig into it, and my hope is this,
Sathya Narayanan: whether you use ChatGPT or Cloud or Gemini, with the guidance set up on this… on this dojo is going to help you
Sathya Narayanan: Dig into it. So please, work on this.
Sathya Narayanan: you know, preferably this week, right? Like, kind of finish it up. And the last thing I want to mention, I think as many of you saw and even responded to my email, I sent an email about, like, this plan we have. We are, you know, we are building this plane as we are… we are flying it. We do have this hope for a…
Sathya Narayanan: networking event on the last week. We are going to bring
Sathya Narayanan: engineers, hiring managers, people from the industry to come talk to you. And I mentioned in the email about that's going to be invitation-only, and what I mean by invitation-only is
Sathya Narayanan: We would like to have students at least completed the first four weeks of our… our activities to be in that… to be included in that.
Sathya Narayanan: You know, this is not to punish you or anything like that. We want to be able to say something to those people, saying that these are students who will have A, B, and C.
Sathya Narayanan: And we'll say A, B, and C based on the first 4 weeks, but then if you come in without having done that, we are losing credit with… credibility with the people we are inviting, right? So this is kind of… we are trying to do…
Sathya Narayanan: our best to do some matchmaking to help you, and we are using our connections. So just please keep that in mind. Again, yeah, I hope that inspires you. I'm not trying to threaten you or anything. I hope it inspires you to dig in and
Sathya Narayanan: get value out of the ideas we are proposing. So yeah, that's… those are announcements I wanted to make. I know I went a minute… minute over. Any questions on anything… anything I have said?
Sathya Narayanan: If you're behind and all that catch-up, don't worry about it. There's no kind of due date and all that. We put due dates, but just for suggestion, like, you know, as long as you do the work, you know, we are happy, yeah.
Sathya Narayanan: Any questions for me or for Jeff?
Monalisa Nchinda: For, like, feedback on our resumes, do we submit it to that link that you shared prior?
Sathya Narayanan: The… the… what I just shared is for the activity you just did.
Sathya Narayanan: Okay. But thanks for asking that question. So, I don't know if you noticed in my email, we are planning to make Thursday's session kind of like this more open
Sathya Narayanan: if you can join, we'll have breakout room for, like, each of us to kind of talk to you. We need to time it, depending on how many people are there, but probably 10 minutes, we can look at your resume, give you feedback, just…
Sathya Narayanan: connect with us and talk, and we will try to help you. All four of us will be there, and we'll try to help you. So that would be a good way to kind of get feedback from us.
Monalisa Nchinda: Okay, and that would be this Thursday?
Sathya Narayanan: That'll be this Thursday, and next Thursday… and next Thursday after that, I think. So at least for the next two Thursdays, we are planning to do that as kind of a work session.
Monalisa Nchinda: Okay.
Adrian Vo: Also, at the same time.
Sathya Narayanan: No, that is at, I said it in the email, 3.30 to 5, I believe.
Sathya Narayanan: Okay, so we will post a reminder, I think Nicholas will post a reminder on Slack, with the same Zoom call.
Sathya Narayanan: So just… yeah, there is an email from me, look at the email so you'll see that also, but it's 3.30 to 5, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: And any more questions, please, please hop in. Two quick things I wanted to put out, again, from the Ashby call earlier. One,
Jeff D'Andria: said, I guess, with the resume important, and then also, sometimes companies will have a couple, like, free response questions.
Jeff D'Andria: In their, say, applicant tracking system, free response.
Jeff D'Andria: Apparently, those are becoming more and more important.
Jeff D'Andria: Especially as, whatever, AI and resumes, and it's, like, everyone's resume's really good now, so…
Jeff D'Andria: he said, do not… like, really a bad look if you put that question in ChatGBT or something, and say, give me a good answer for this. In fact, like, it sounds like many answers are starting to sound the same. So use that, so use that human element, answer it, you know, yourself. And then the other thing he said was.
Jeff D'Andria: A personal portfolio is one way to
Jeff D'Andria: Release yourself from the confines of a one-page limit.
Jeff D'Andria: And really be able to talk about all the other stuff that just never would fit on one page. And, you know, with AI vibe coding, it's not very hard to make those anymore, so…
Jeff D'Andria: Shows that extra effort. Personal portfolio. Even for the non…
Jeff D'Andria: If you're in, like, a major that's not computer science.
Sathya Narayanan: I… if… I don't know, Jeff, did you want to do one more student example or something like that, or should we let them go? Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Oh yeah, I mean, I think we're over time now. Yeah. I'm glad to stay, and if anyone wants to come off and, you know.
Jeff D'Andria: do another, but I think… I think we're good, yeah.
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, I would just highly recommend, you know, putting the…
Jeff D'Andria: fill out those highlights, like the… what's on the dock, and… and put that in play. It's a good adjustment to try, especially if you're… we gotta try something different, if it's… if you're not getting the results, so…